if you're trying to figure out where to
start with your business
you don't know anything about it go get
some experience in the industry
otherwise your chances of failure are
going to be really high
and i don't want you to lose your shirt
lose your money lose your time going
down the wrong path
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hunger entrepreneurs deserve help
today i mentioned a question from one of
my facebook readers roy
thanks for writing in roy roy said i
like the way you help people here
thank you roy i would like to have a
suggestion from you i'm a student
doing master's in structural engineering
i want to set a construction company i
don't know where to start i have the
workforce
but i need to know how to get financial
support and i want some suggestions
thank you roy hey roy congrats i want to
start a business it's
great news i'm excited for you here's
the thing
if you start a business now you're
probably going to fail because you have
no experience
in it it's great to know the technical
skills but you have to know how to run a
business
i don't want you to go out hire a bunch
of people to work for you
hire a team have to pay these people
every week and not have business come in
and you end up having to close your
doors you lose your savings
and you go up getting some job that you
hate the path to success here for you is
you have to learn about the business
you have to know what makes one of these
companies successful go
work or intern summer job part-time job
full-time job on a limited basis
whatever it is go
work for a company that you respect
who's done it who has a team
learn about the industry see if it's for
you understand how it works
understand how they make money put the
pieces together so when you go launch
your business
you're ready to go you give yourself the
best chance of success
and when you do it you build around the
customer don't go out and hire a big
workforce
bring out a bunch of costs start small
you bootstrap it up
find a customer who has a pain has a
need and will pay you to solve it for
them
you don't need a lot of money to start a
service based business
you don't need any money it's your time
if somebody has a problem you can solve
it and they'll pay you for it
you're in business congratulations and
if you need to bring on people
subcontractors do it you said you had
the team ready to go
but they're all part-time workers
subcontractors until you are able to get
this to a point
where you have more stability so that's
how you start
learn and get paid to do it by working
at another company who you respect
a small shop where you can learn a lot
of the ins and outs figure out the
business is for you
and how they make money how they
generate business then when you start
you're bootstrapping you start small you
don't need a huge financial investment
just go find a customer
it's a service based business find
someone who has a pain
solve it for them get paid for it hire
people if you need to
put the money back into your business
and go off to the next client
it's the best way to build your company
good luck roy thanks for the question
great question
for those of you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
and i also want to hear from you please
leave a comment under this video i love
seeing them come in i always read them
i really appreciate it if you're
commenting on this video or you have a
question for your own business please
leave it below thank you guys
i'll see you soon